for youtubers and streamers online
harassment is
unfortunately pretty normal hopefully
it's called out
shut down and they can move on but what
happens when that online harassment
moves into the real world
when your harasser shows up at your home
well if you're youtuber boogie2988
you open the door with a pistol in hand
and fire
a warning shot trying to scare them off
now a year later boogie has a warrant
out for his arrest on charges of
aggravated assault
for doing exactly that
[Music]
alright guys like the video subscribe to
the channel and hit that notification
bell so you never miss new content ever
again also
leave a comment below about how much you
love my hand gestures
and if you have a story that you want to
see here on don't at me
send a tip to tips at thescore.com late
on monday night
a bunch of twitter and youtube drama
accounts tweeted out
that youtuber boogie2988 had a warrant
out for his arrest on charges of
aggravated assault
a little while later boogie joked about
the warrant using
an old photo of him but then he did
confirm that the warrant is real
and that he is cooperating fully with
the authorities quote
so news circulating around me can't
really comment for obvious reasons
thank you to anyone for support in this
situation though
i'm gonna do the right thing and do it
by the book glad to cooperate with
authorities
heading home today to do so end quote
now in order to give you a better
understanding of how we got here
let's back up to where this all started
boogie started uploading videos to
youtube back in 2006
and is a og creator on the platform
his 4.24 million subscribers watch
everything from his gaming content to
his old comedy skits
to personal reflections about what's
going on in his life
boogie is also pretty controversial and
over the years he's found himself in the
receiving end of
some pretty harsh criticism from both
his fan base
but also the wider gaming community love
him or hate him if you're a die-hard
youtube person
you probably know who he is the story
behind the warrant for boogie's arrest
begins with a feud with fellow youtuber
frank hassell
which began sometime in the summer of
2020. as a youtuber
hassel's content primarily focused on
him
hassling random members of the public
you know hassle hassling you get it his
channel was eventually deleted from the
platform after youtube
found that his content violated its
terms of service
now for whatever reason hassel believed
that boogie was responsible for getting
his channel deleted and because of that
he began
harassing boogie incessantly online for
months
repeatedly saying he was going to drive
down to boogie's home
and confront him the situation and
harassment escalated to the point where
it caught the attention of keemstar
and in typical keemstar fashion he
invited both of them on his drama alert
show
to interview them frank you did go down
to dixon street last night take a photo
tag me in that photo and then say i'm in
your town see
right that was you oh that's on your
twitter feed right now
yes that was me i am in dixonville right
now and i am in fayetteville arkansas
all right well cool man let me make it
very clear you should be very glad you
didn't step on my property
okay and i highly recommend you don't
it'll be the
last decision you can make things
escalated when
hassel took the [ __ ] talking offline and
into the real world
posting to twitter and then stating in
the keemstar interview
that he had in fact driven down to
boogie's hometown
of fayetteville arkansas from there the
interview got
incredibly intense with boogie
threatening to take
quote defensive action against hassell
if he showed up to his home and
continued to threaten boogie
his roommate or his dog i i told you
very clearly i don't give a [ __ ] what
happens to me and that's fine
but if there's a risk for me my dog or
my roommate
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
take self-defense
caution i'm gonna do winning very over
dramatic and should consider
taking your anxiety medication or
something well i did take my anxiety
medication tonight man and this is
do you understand that this is what you
do to people then on september 28th
hassel did exactly that he showed up to
boogie's home
and continued to antagonize him while
standing outside
now at the time this originally happened
the following events were disputed
and with social media being what it is
there was a [ __ ] ton of speculation
about what exactly went down but we
eventually learned
that yeah buggy came outside to confront
hassel
and he had a gun in his hand not only
that audio
and video eventually surfaced of boogie
repeatedly warning hassle to leave his
property
before firing a warning shot in the air
you have threatened my life
i'm asking you to leave in about 30
seconds i'm going to fire a warning shot
fire it now fire the warning shot now
is this what we have to do boogie then
posted a video after the fact
titled confronting a stalker do not come
to a youtuber's house
in the video he essentially lays out
what happened from his side of the story
i made it abundantly clear to him and
anyone else that would listen
that he was not welcome in my home that
because of his previous threats that i
would
pull a gun on him he goes on to say that
regardless of what you think of him
this harassment and the literal
confrontation outside of his home
is not something that him or anyone
should have to deal with
i know that there are plenty of people
out there who do not like me they do not
like my content
but even i don't deserve this nobody
does
this is not a behavior we can support
from there
a police report was filed stating that a
shot was fired
and eventually things calmed down for
quite a while
this brings us back to the arrest
warrant which we were all made aware of
on may 11th now i reached out to the
sheriff's department
and yes according to them boogie did
turn himself in wednesday morning
he was booked at 7 39 a.m and charged
with aggravated assault
from there the 5 000 bond was paid and
he was released at 10 40 am
while this situation involved two
youtubers this type of incident
involving a stalker which is what boogie
has repeatedly referred to hassle as
is not uncommon online these days it's
actually so common for youtubers and
streamers to have to deal with these
unwanted individuals
that it's unfortunately become
normalized in the internet
news cycle take streamer suite anita for
example back in september
she revealed that she had a stalker
sleeping outside of her home
following her home with a knife and
making repeated threats against her life
sweet anita went to the police but for
months nothing was done about her
situation
and her stalker continued to harass her
we covered that situation on this show
at the time had a stalker they've been
stalking me for quite a few months
actually um they've been coming to my
house
they've been sleeping pretty much in my
backyard watching the house
and the other day
some shopkeepers had to intervene and
kind of
hold him back while he chased after me
another notable incident
involved gaming youtuber meg turney who
back in 2018
had an obsessive fan drive 11 hours with
a gun
in an attempt to kill her husband and
fellow youtuber gavin free
outside of that it's not uncommon to
find clips on the live stream fail
subreddit of streamers both being
harassed in public
but also in their literal homes an
example of this is when cooking streamer
trisha's aberdee
had to abruptly end her stream after an
intruder broke into her home
looking to quote save her
[Music]
i'm not call the police
thankfully that situation ended
peacefully and everyone is okay
because of situations like these
streamers like sweet anita
have long called on twitch and the
authorities to do
something to better protect the people
using the platform
and to honestly just take their
situations more seriously
there's been times where i've run out of
coffee in uh
the night before and i'm just too lazy
to go get some for the next morning and
i wake up
and like it's like an addict like
looking for
you know scraps i'm like i'm irritated
i'm angry
if i don't get a [ __ ] coffee it's
like the whole i can't start my day
properly then i drank too much coffee
and the result is often what's in this
[ __ ] end board where i'm just like